[Música]
por supuesto salud te hablamos también
aquí en directo américa ya está conmigo
en el estudio más romeros a la mar
bienvenida feliz mañana de viernes esta
semana fue ya la semana porque ya está
cerrando para la inmunización global mar
que significa esto y que trabajo se está
haciendo todavía quedan dos días
que también se trabajan muchos de
nuestros compañeros por cierto bueno
estamos hablando de esfuerzos masivos
para vacunar a toda la población en
todos los lugares del mundo sobre todo
centrados en la infancia pero no contra
el kobe 19 sino contra otras
enfermedades hablamos por ejemplo de
sarampión de polio de difteria que todas
estas campañas que solían ser rutinarias
de vacunación sobre todo para los niños
y para las niñas se vieron interrumpidas
por la pandemia de kobe 19 no sólo por
el colapso generalizado de los sistemas
sanitarios sino también porque por
ejemplo la gente tenía miedo de
acercarse a los puntos de vacunación por
contagiarse y también porque esta
desconfianza que se ha popularizado
contra las vacunas del cobi 19 también
se ha visto un poco como ha estado
afectando a otros tipos de campañas de
vacunación a pesar de pues fármacos que
ya estaban totalmente normalizados en
los que no había mucho problema con
vacunar a los niños sin embargo estas
bajas tasas de vacunación de estas otras
enfermedades ya están empezando a tener
consecuencias en varias regiones del
mundo y le pregunto más precisamente
cuáles son estas consecuencias pues si
te parece vamos primero al continente
africano donde hemos visto que han
habido ya rey brotes de varias de estas
enfermedades que se pueden prevenir con
una vacuna estamos hablando por ejemplo
del sarampión esta enfermedad se
cuadruplicó los casos de esta enfermedad
se cuadruplicaron en los primeros meses
de 2022 respecto al 2021 la sarampión es
una enfermedad extremadamente contagiosa
entonces podemos esperar que esto se
agrave en los próximos meses también
hubo un brotes de polio en cuatro países
más en 2021 respecto a 2020 en total en
24 países y algo parecido sucedió con la
fiebre amarilla donde se registraron
casos en 13 países cuatro más que en
2020 a pesar de que ninguno de estos
casos está agarrando pues tasas
alarmantes vemos que es un síntoma de
que están bajando estas vacunaciones y
quienes son los más afectados por esta
baja de vacunación por la falta de
vacunas vamos a centrarnos en un
conjunto de población digamos que se
llaman a los niños cero dosis son a
todas esas personas en la infancia que
no han recibido ninguna vacuna este
número incremento en tres millones
respecto a 2020 y pues la organización
mundial de la salud desde áfrica nos
alertaba de esta forma
a los niños con cero dosis están en un
riesgo mucho mayor de mortalidad pero
además es importante encontrar estos
niños porque son una bandera roja en una
comunidad o en una familia sumisos
son familias que tienen probabilidad de
ser más vulnerables en términos de
pobreza seguridad alimentaria acceso a
anticonceptivos las vulnerabilidades son
multifactoriales y no sólo debemos
combatir los brotes de enfermedades sino
también preguntarnos por qué hay tan
poca vacunación en esa área y quiénes
son los más vulnerables
claro esto nos vuelve hablar un poco de
esa relación que hay entre pobreza y
salud y que no sólo estas campañas
masivas de vacunación van a solucionar
el problema sino también mejorar las
condiciones de vida globales las
consecuencias marc que viviremos si no
se cumplen estos objetivos globales de
vacunación pues va más allá de estos
rebrotes puntuales que vemos en áfrica
estas consecuencias pueden extenderse en
los años y será a largo plazo y de hecho
no muy distinto sucede esto en el
continente americano por eso la
directora de la organización
panamericana de la salud
también nos advertía así
y los últimos dos años nos han hecho
retroceder tres décadas en la vacunación
contra el sarampión y la polio y nos han
dejado en riesgo de reintroducción
we are a girl's
inversión cover hoy estamos de nuevo en
los mismos niveles de vacunación
reportados en 1994 cuando estas
enfermedades todavía eran un grave
riesgo para la infancia las familias y
las comunidades
de tristram hunt y news si esta
situación persiste pagaremos un precio
extremadamente alto en pérdida de vidas
en más discapacidades y en costos
económicos genómica
y normas
financieros
entonces vemos que esto puede ser a
largo plazo por ejemplo con la polio qué
causa que la gente mucha gente quede
pues con discapacidades repasemos las
cifras y las tasas de vacunación en
américa latina y en el caribe la
organización mundial de la salud
considera que se necesita el 95 por
ciento de cobertura de vacunación para
evitar rebrotes de estas enfermedades y
vemos que en el caso por ejemplo de la
polio del sarampión no se está logrando
tampoco con la vacuna triple vírica que
protege de tres enfermedades la tos
ferina el tétanos y también la difteria
esto es grave sobre todo teniendo en
cuenta por ejemplo que américa latina
había eliminado la polio en
1994 mientras que ahora mismo pues uno
de cuatro de cada cuatro niños en esta
región no cuenta con la pauta completa
entonces aprovechemos también hoy para
además que por cierto raúl del 21 de
abril es el día de la inmunología para
recordar que las vacunas son la
herramienta más importante que tenemos
para prevenir enfermedades una
herramienta que ya existe y que podemos
usar para mejorar la calidad de vida de
muchas personas 100% tomar muchísimas
gracias como siempre por toda la
información vamos a ver ahora otra
entrevista especial en el marco de la
del libro internacional de la ciudad de
bogotá